horizon forbidden west offers way more
combat options than in horizon zero dawn
and that can be daunting with a bunch of
new weapons items and abilities on offer
let me help you take out anything or
anyone that stands in your way with some
useful combat tips if you enjoy horizon
forbidden west content let us know with
a like
valor surges are one of the most useful
new techniques in horizon forbidden west
and can be multifunctional valor surges
not only have amazing effects when
activated you're invincible during the
cool animation itself so it's great as a
defensive measure
any valor surge when timed will can be
used to dodge deadly attacks and on top
of that you can use this time to d-pad
up and start healing yourself with
berries during the animation giving you
a head start on your self-patching
progress in horizon zero dawn dodge
rolling was the main state of dodging
attacks giving you invincibility frames
but sliding was somewhat of an
afterthought not giving too much value
in combat forbidden west has upped the
ante by making sliding an essential
skill and making it invincible for a
short time as well so to maximize on
your dodge time first hit the ground
running
then slide then dodge roll this entire
duration is completely immune to attacks
and basically doubles your distance
traveled and time spent invincible
if you're a big fan of tripwires and
zero dawn i've got some bad news for you
they've been nerfed pretty bad the
damage is still great but the placement
has been heavily toned down with
tripwires breaking much more often if
you space them too far apart placed at
odd angles or on strange terrain also
all traps in general compared to zero
dawn can be self-triggered this time
around so keep this in mind as you're
trying to surprise the enemy if you're
not careful you might eat a face full of
your own plants
there are skills to unlock to reduce the
damage done to yourself so if you're
adamant about maximizing your trapping
pick these perks first because blowing
yourself up is bound to happen
there are a ton of ways to customize
your experience in the settings in
forbidden west so here are some key ones
for combat that you may want to consider
turning on or off while playing the game
try messing around with the weapon wheel
slow down speeds initially the normal
speed doesn't slow down the game much
but turning it down to the slowest
setting will give you much more time to
think about your equipment switch while
in a hectic fight another setting i
personally recommend is the weapon quick
swap option especially if you like
swapping between two weapons over and
over this will ease the headache of
going into the menu every single time it
allows you to switch between your last
two weapons by just tapping l1 instead
of holding it down and pulling up the
weapon wheel if you're playing on ps5
mess around with some test fights with
favorite performance or favor resolution
although horizon isn't a one frame link
intensive fighting game by all means the
extra frames do help alloy feel a little
more snappy during battles so test out
your preference and see what fits you
best
one of forbidden west's new weapons the
javelin is probably more useful than you
think their hefty payload not only does
damage on impact but very often stuns
enemies for a brief second against very
aggressive enemies this stun comes very
clutch and if you get explosive javelins
they get stun and damage on impact and
stun and damage on explosion and
absolutely destroy armor i highly
recommend always having some javelins in
your equipment wheel
jump off attacks are a new addition to
aeloy's melee combat repertoire by
holding heavy attack right after a
single light attack this will plant your
feet on the enemy and jump off of them
striking them with an arrow during this
jump off will do extra damage as well
leading to a fancy combo always remember
that the jump off direction is
influenced by which direction you hold
after planting your feet so for the best
arrow follow-up option hold back towards
you otherwise you'll jump forward
forcing you to do a full 360 to do this
follow-up option which is a royal pain
one advanced technique i ran into is the
half moon cancel holding a light attack
will charge up aloy's spear this can be
released into an attack that rushes down
enemies and slashes for decent damage
called the half moon slash a side note
this can be used to link into the
aforementioned jump off attack
cool thing though is the moment the half
moon slash is released you can jump or
roll so who cares well this leads to
some really cool options such as double
jump attacks or double rolling pretty
nifty so combine your slide and hold
light attack then dodge roll then
release attack and dodge roll a second
time for a really long evasive window
when it comes to valor surges you may
pick and choose many options based on
how you play which is really nice
whether it be you prefer stealth high
defense options or for me i like high
offense and damage capabilities you can
preview these perk upgrades by pressing
triangle over each valor surge during
your choosing process though remember
that each valor surge has three levels
and on the final third level when
unlocked usually has an extra ability
that really might change your mind for
better or for worse level three critical
boost gives a little more critical
damage and chance or level three tough
end to negates blind and defin status
not bad i guess but compare those two to
something like melee might which gives
infinite spear energy and a bunch of
knock down capabilities basically the
ability to completely cover enemies and
resonator blasts for satisfying bubble
wrap popping follow-ups
or radial blast which not only does
insane damage by itself and looks
amazing but also doubles all your damage
on follow-up attacks for 15 seconds or
chain burst which on paper doesn't sound
quite as fun as some massive electrical
explosion until you find out that it has
the best crowd control ability that's
borderline broken
not only does damage and elemental build
up spread out towards multiple enemies
but the small stun it does also spreads
to every enemy as well
basically locking down an entire squad
all this gameplay is on very hard mode
by the way showing just how powerful
this is just make sure to do your
homework first and read every
description so you know what to
prioritize first if not at least make a
save with skill points stocked up so you
can give each fowler upgrade a trial run
in real combat and if one's not your cup
of tea simply reload your save and build
something you prefer
smoke bombs are an obvious way to escape
enemies with a distraction for a brief
moment even usable underwater like a
squid using ink to escape but they can
also be used offensively against some
enemies to give you a window to sneak
strike them
just keep in mind this won't work
against tougher enemies
when using grapple points get in the
consistent rhythm of grappling then
pressing dodge to jump off vertically in
combat this is a nice vantage point to
keep you on the move and get a shot off
on enemies from above with a caveat if
you land you'll get stuck in a super
long landing animation making you easy
pickings for any enemy wanting to come
by and give ailoy a knock on the head
so get in the habit of gliding then
going for a shot or vice versa shooting
then gliding back down to keep the flow
of combat going or you can tap or hold
l2 to be in aiming mode while landing to
negate landing lag entirely although i
believe this is a bug so it may be
patched at some point
and there you have it 10 combat tips to
help you dominate the forbidden west let
us know if any of these tips helped and
if you enjoy horizon forbidden west we
have a full story recap and graphics
comparison for you to check out for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot